what is your price prediction for the
end of year bitcoin we're in a massive
bull market uh we saw what happened in
2017 what do you think happens through
the rest of this year
okay
150 000. wow what's your reasoning for
150 000
because i'm incredibly optimistic um
i think that i think that might be low
i think no i think well
if we if if things start hopping
and momentum moves and the fed does what
it does in the way that it's been doing
things and that signals the next group
of people to go after it yes i i mean
it's above 150 000. i also think we're
experiencing inflation like we've never
before and so bitcoins are naturally
worth more us dollars so it's like it's
a no-brainer to own some bitcoin in your
portfolio uh that's not investment
advice i think i'm supposed to say that
in terms of conditions and conditions
everyone yeah put it in the terms and
conditions
yeah we actually have our audience is
such nerds that they sit at night by
candlelight and they read the terms and
conditions we've we've trained them
they're they're awesome okay good please
please do uh this is not investment
advice i am not a financial advisor like
just stroll it after this all right one
percent what percentage is a follow-on
question what percentage of your
portfolio is bitcoin versus other things
do you think so
uh 30
so we've been going after these inspired
networks uh for a while now more than
just bitcoin for a while now
and uh we've we've been consistent about
about 30 so 30 of our deals we've
invested in about 120
crypto related startups over the course
of the last nine years uh so we've one
of the larger portfolios there uh some
of those companies are things i mean
we're in coinbase we're in rpo we're in
shake pay we're in unstoppable domains
nifty gateway ether scan like we we've
lot we jump started a market and we're
very proud of that
what else are you investing in you said
vr
you said oceans you said all kinds of
stuff what what else
like when you wake up in the middle of
the night you're like man this is a big
opportunity what else are you investing
in
uh it's it's it's wherever the soul's
being inspired my friend uh
so the i think that the next thing that
people are gonna be surprised by is
virtual reality because uh there are
there is a headset called the quest 2
that is actually the vr the way that you
think it should be um and there are 8
million headsets out there companies are
making tens of millions of dollars a
year like it's a business this is a
market um but the things that i uh i
love are v1
industries like crypto was like
incentivizing v1 industries is sort of
my uh where where the soul is inspired
um the
the one that i i like is popping into my
head that i'm obsessed with is oceans
because for climate change
to be fixed
we have to fix the regulator of the
earth's temperature which is the ocean
it's out of whack we got to clean it up
and so you know we just backed a company
that's
it's a
robot to clean for healthier oceans uh
called holbot
we've backed a company called coral vita
that does restoration of coral uh and
it's awesome like they regrow coral
using a process called micro fracturing
so it grows like 50-year
coral farms in like two years um and
like the so
basically just
i try to go where we find these inspired
people and there happen to be a high
density of them in oceans in crypto in
virtual reality and then aerospace i
mean if you see someone build a jet pack
and they fly
you invest
that's true probably that's
that's just that's just like any
investment thesis like if you actually
see them fly
you invest and so we've done two because
i've seen two fly
what's up guys bang bang thanks so much
for watching the best business show
today if we're gonna be the best
business show we obviously need the best
partner that's why the exclusive sponsor
the best business show is sofi they're
an all-in-one platform that allows you
to invest in all kinds of different
assets including stocks etfs crypto ipos
and they even have an automated
investing function if that's your thing
so before we start getting after it
again make sure that you go download
sofi you get an invest account and when
you make your first crypto trade
regardless of what you buy they'll give
you 10 in bitcoin for free it's that
simple head on over to sofi.com to get
started today thanks so much for
watching and i hope you come back and
watch more the best business show
tomorrow
[Music]